multi-vitamins you guys have probably
heard about this already it's all over
the news there are three new studies
saying that multivitamins don't do jack
that's right three studies came out and
said this let's take a look at the
author's conclusion this was published
in the annals of internal medicine we
believe that the case is closed
supplementing the diet of well nourished
adults with most mineral or vitamin
supplements has no clear benefit and
might even be harmful these vitamins
should not be used for chronic disease
prevention
enough is enough as a lifelong user of
Flintstone vitamins this is very
disturbing to me so before we get into
the study do you guys use multivitamins
do you take a multivitamin every day
there was a period of time where I was
taking vitamins every single day and I
was mostly doing it because I wanted
nicer skin and nails and hair biotin
okay so I was taking biotin for a while
and I I took it for over a year and it
did nothing so I finally decided to stop
wasting my money on it I was taking
other vitamins by the way because I care
about my health as well as beauty but
whatever but I did realize after doing
some research that the jury is still out
when it comes to supplements and I think
a really important thing to keep in mind
is the claims made by all of these
companies that make supplements those
claims have not been reviewed by the FDA
so they can just straight out lie to you
they can say stuff like may support bone
health for instance and the FDA doesn't
review that so they can just straight
out lie to you and just the fact that
they use the word may allows them to you
know get out of any type of situation
where they might get sued right because
they can say wait we didn't say that
it's definite it's may may support bone
and they're giving you six hundred
percent of this when technically you'd
think you would only need a hundred
percent of something do you do use a
multivitamin I do not use a multivitamin
because I care about neither my beauty
nor my health I think in that quotation
that you showed I think it bears
mentioning that said in adults with a
balanced diet right and we live in
America and I don't know executor I know
nothing
medically about this but I would say
that that suggests that if you're eating
you know Doritos and Diet Pepsi as your
primary diet you might need some kind of
supplement I'm guessing yeah so I want
to get to some of the nutrition stuff so
there was no solid evidence for or
against vitamins and minerals alone or
for a multivitamin to prevent heart
disease or cancer it found enough
evidence to recommend against taking
beta carotene or vitamin E for
preventing both diseases and beta
carotene may raise risk for lung cancer
for already at-risk individuals that
seems pretty bonkers the multivitamin
did nothing to slow cognitive decline
among men 65 and older compared to
placebo takers and there was no
difference in rates of another heart
attack chest pain or rates of stroke and
early death between vitamin takers and
placebo takers okay that I do take a
daily placebo yeah but if you know it's
a placebo then it really can't do
anything but this goes to what you are
getting you don't do anything because I
expect it to not do anything because
it's a placebo
that's pretty meta which means it could
maybe do something so some of this
though seems a little obvious to me like
we should be getting our nutrients and
our minerals from our food so should we
not there is no magic bullet really
right there isn't I think that we live
in a society that wants to fix
everything with a pill oh you're not
feeling happy well here's something that
a pharmaceutical company can offer you
take it and it'll solve all your
problems and we like to self-medicate we
like to think that if we take something
orally it'll make us feel better it'll
make us healthier and stronger and
prettier and all that the reality is you
got to focus on your diet you got to
focus on exercise the only time that
you're gonna get positive benefits out
of your actions is when you actually do
the difficult thing and that's eating
healthy and exercising what is that very
not the American Way which goes to what
you were saying before I think you know
we there is no way you can advertise and
profit from people taking care of
themselves on their own it's very it's
very difficult to find a way to profit
on that you can sell those shoes
like there's a couple little things you
could do some water bottles but
ultimately yeah you know this is a pure
marketing scheme and it always was just
talking earlier about they can say
whatever they want in the advertisements
as long as not after my favorite ever
medical advertising phrase was may
provide transient relief in certain mild
instances that's a genius piece of
marketing right there this there's a
chance that this will help for a little
while if the problem wasn't bad to begin
with right that's what that is but it
sounds as though they're selling you
something worthwhile and you know we
know that the placebo effect is is
valuable we know that you can give
people a pill that does nothing and if
they believe it's doing something it
helps and I think a lot of the the
marketing and the sales and the
promotion of supplements and herbal
remedies is all about people just
wanting to feel as though they are doing
something without taking action and
personally I like to feel that my entire
career is a process of me feeling that
I'm doing something without taking
action but before we get too caught up
in these studies isn't this one of these
things where like one week you hear that
it doesn't work and then the next week
you're gonna hear it does you know it's
like when I was a kid I remember there
saying my grandma always wanted me to
eat the yolk of the egg and then it was
like then you weren't supposed to eat
the yolk like it's just when coffee
right coffee is good for you this week
then the next week it's bad for me isn't
it one of these things that like these
studies come out and then okay for you
can believe it but at the end of the day
I think maybe a strong case can be made
about supplements acting as supplements
right you eat a healthy you know healthy
diet you exercise you do what you need
to do and then you supplement your diet
for any nutrients that you might be
missing out on vitamins really a
supplement not a replacement exactly I
think a lot of people think of it as a
replacement but clearly there are some
vitamins that are effective I mean
there's a reason why pregnant women are
told that they need to take prenatal
vitamins and folic acid that helps the
development of the fetus so there has to
be some sort of medical research
supporting that otherwise why would all
these women be forced to take folic acid
it you know I mean you can get
conspiratorial you can get super
conspiratorial with that but I think
that you know there is a button by the
way the one time that I did take a
vitamin and it did make some sort of
impact was when I took prenatal vitamins
I wasn't pregnant
yeah you can take prenatal I was taking
them because I wanted my hair to grow
faster and it did so it did something I
have to dispute the idea that this is
like coffee and the studies were they
didn't find out it is and then you find
out it isn't because this is not counter
to some other study this is a scientific
study a peer-reviewed scientific study
that is up against advertising and when
the study that comes out that you
imagine would come up that was counter
to it it is only going to be coming out
as a corporate sponsored study all right
so last thought on this you know it sort
of goes to what you were saying about
the pharmaceutical end of this stuff you
know if you watch any of these
commercials and we talk about all the
time of the show you know all every pill
for depression or for to quit smoking
whatever diarrhea sudden death suicidal
thoughts horrible dreams blah blah blah
for multivitamin yeah yeah the whole the
whole ten commandments the whole shebang
but from as far as I could tell you
could take a multivitamin you still
don't have any bad side effects so is
there any reason not to just keep taking
it other than that you're then just
feeding the Machine apart from your
feeding that apart from the one where it
might cause increased risk of lung
cancer I think that's a thing I think
you know I frankly if you're smoking
your vitamins I think you've gone off
the deep end already yeah yeah no I
think I think probably you can cause
harm ultimately you're changing the
balance the chemical balance in your
body